welcome to this video playing IBS from
Brazil ok and last game I got very nice
winning the classical Kings Indian
against international master John Bryant
on the US maybe I get the same line
again with 92 i really don't know it
well but the term it served me well in
this game ok a five I know they play III
here ok B 6 is quite uncommon because it
weakens the queenside but ok and to
prepare before in one move ok now h5
yeah well before I started here so let's
let's push that hmm yeah you know what
is strange here if he wants to play a 5
y and y play H file first how too hard
too hard to understand ok I'm going to
go see 5 immediately arm I don't think I
need to prepare it much if he takes
twice i have night c4 Bishop e3 this
kind of thing ok so he's just content
Bishop age 6 mm okay well I can do this
and just play this position uh-huh so
ok so I'm I do I take 1d6 on or not
there is no tactic yeah based on this
Bishop looks a bit weird
hmm yeah not really don't see one okay
that's creepy i would see one looks like
that
yeah I can take now playbook be six but
it's not leading to much can take on c4
all the time but I had prepared that
anyway and maybe I could have played f4
in this position right away hmm ok
victim cannot i think all day yeah he's
playing quickly so i should make sure
that I'm not falling super far behind on
the clock and ultimately lose on time in
a good position ok so what am i doing
now this is a bit of an annoying pin
here might be five is however nice if I
get it in Seoul let's get the Queen out
of there prepare a 95
I can also think about like c6 rugby 795
for playing and c7 and yeah i'm waiting
for his f5 move which is not coming not
sure one problem of this move is that ok
it's kind of shocking the teacher stir
gives away the the exchange here ok but
what is the idea let's say hmm cheeks
hmm if i take the id-5 is weak the fiber
somewhat weak then ok and if i go f3 and
still the right move i think because it
keeps the night only seven a bad piece
yeah so Bishop to d3 I guess to cover
reform and I'm intending to capture on
d6 and play Queen system ok by doing
that now am I between a 5s also have
let's do that intending to take on d6 he
doesn't really have a great square for
the Queen Queen f8 or something ok I can
just take a take on c5
yeah the parts on lefroy d5 restrict the
nights which is very important he cannot
use his nights and actively oh aha that
said so that's not so great what did i
do here yeah the only way to get in
trouble in this game is we're looking
stuff like that okay so Queen c7 ya can
do that Queen f6 is not threatening much
really yeah that wasn't necessary at all
didn't didn't see this head oya just
blunder this okay so what now should be
five yeah this is good right nie def
6690 47 and I'm promoting
Saudi 797 look c7 and that's it right d
797 brookside morning nope no square is
some continuing a piece down I can you
form
44 seconds should be check more than
enough what I have to to speed up a
little bit
how I'm actually doing this hmm my case
getting in there on the docks class I
really I really want to have the
third-ranked yeah do I get this somehow
don't don't really see them and concrete
win at the moment look over to g4 would
be nice but I don't get this don't get
this in at the moment yeah the time this
is the problem here it's not a totally
it is a trivial win but do it do it in
13 seconds ah what a crap what the
corrupt situation here you check it's
totally one sided gay i have where he
was a check never ever doing anything
and and now it said no it's easy
actually with ruga five but check I
don't have the time anymore to finish
that check check
check check check white orchids oh yeah
that's the problem with this town
control if you spend too long I mean
gave me this was a really the effort can
you say he was basically losing from
here about so it's just a terrible
position v6h 5 9 8 7 this is all or
really really bad but ok i was i was
just playing this a bit slow on the slow
side and i took took far too long I mean
okay this is this wasn't necessary it is
completely winning but it took to cart
along in this in this technical position
here how is what is the most convincing
way to do this action they look these
six Bishop group d 6 Bishop EA it
probably yeah oh I had this straps the
rook and that's that's that's much
easier right I am ok check and just I
just spent far too much time here look
look here and h4 g3 this is always also
sometimes a problem you're in this
situation and you know that it's going
to be a little bit tricky with the time
and this is the most frustrating loss
yeah they never threaten anything in the
game and would lose every game with
increment but okay if we continue and so
on here it's not I mean it's not so not
so so straightforward to find a win
because I'm I don't get to the e4 pawn
that easily what is what is the way to
do it actually then what is the simplest
way to do it
hmm yeah maybe look I want to I want to
get to the third rank here so maybe like
here and rook rook to be three something
like that so that the King can actually
move in the game and he allowed that it
was I mean people just play moves anyway
to win on time so the check is not chat
really check important check so here i
was i was coming coming coming to this
and this is what I just need to achieve
so that I will win the pawns it's just a
step-by-step process now I mean I didn't
have any time I went through k 6 and ya
know this is of this is now pretty easy
I just have to to get to the pawns it
will take some time this is the problem
it's not something that you can do in in
five moves so this is why I probably a
better better win the rook on instead of
right tion even if when you blundered
the rook here this is a a little bit
easier you know but to what to take from
this game besides time management is
that yeah well this is you don't weaken
the queenside voluntarily and this in
this position and this is just I don't
know nie Dage seven you never ever get
to play a five now yeah because you're
Queen the King side is so weak that that
you don't don't stand this move and on
the queenside you already busted so this
is a strategically almost lost position
for black as we saw in the game but my
technical play was just too bad okay
thanks for watching